vous parlez du salon de la moto qui
s'est ouvert aujourd'hui au palais des
congrès à montréal 150 exposants sont
sur place une des vedettes du salon une
moto 100 % électrique 100 % québécoise
karine bastien voici la sora la première
moto électrique fabriquée au québec peu
bruyante ne dégage pas de chaleur ni
d'odeur elle fait tourner les regards
moi j'aurais beaucoup de plaisir là au
niveau du son sur tout leur a dit pis le
togo moi c'est la touche a accroché
aussi là c'est surtout sur le fait que
ces silencieux c'est impressionnait le
bruit s'est passé pro bruyère céder
après plus de cinquante travail
l'entreprise de longueuil
lito green motion la lancer sur le
marché première monte au monde avec un
siège électrique donc qui permet
d'ajuster la hauteur du pilote seulement
en appuyant sur un bouton écran tactile
gps un paquet d'innovation aussi c'est
un ordinateur sur deux roues en fait là
et puis le haut niveau des performances
en fait on parle de vitesse maximale de
190 km heure d'accélération de zéro sans
4.8 secondes
elle se charge avec une prise
conventionnelle et a une autonomie de
200 kilomètres selon le fabricant
son prix 48 1500 $ pour le travail au
lieu des placements même tout les jours
ça pourrait être intéressant ça faire
l'homme est certain que les prix d'un
groupe d'un gros obstacle actuellement
j'ai trouvé ça extrêmement intéressant
parce que sa fine pointe de la
technologie
puis ça va sûrement s'améliorer mais
c'est encore extrêmement
le fabricant n'a pas l'intention de
baisser ses prix son produit s'adresse à
une certaine élite 90 % des acheteurs se
trouvent en europe notamment en france
en suisse et en allemagne
cet avion dans des objectifs d'une
centaine de véhicules fabriqués
on a une première page de dix qui sort
déjà la semaine prochaine au niveau des
livraisons clients
et puis seulement cela non seulement il
existait déjà des motos électriques en
europe mais est ce qu'il existe un
marché pour les motos électriques haut
de gamme
la vraie réponse personne le sait juste
personne ne sait ils sont en train de
faire quelque chose de très très
ambitieux de 2
de très risqué aussi s'il n'y a pas de
ils sont en terre inconnue difficile de
dire comment les consommateurs vont
réagir à cette nouvelle venue mais déjà
plus d'une quarantaine de motos sera
sont vendus ici car une bastien radio
canada montréal